[Music]
these days Warren Buffett likes to say
he's on the hunt for elephant size
acquisitions but the Oracle of Omaha has
had trouble finding multi-billion dollar
deals that move the needle for his
investment company Berkshire Hathaway
and that's a problem when you have a big
cash pile sitting on your balance sheet
shareholders may worship Buffett and his
co partner Charlie Munger but at some
point they will demand some of that
money back either by share buybacks or
dividends Buffett has argued that his
long term track record of out
performance against the S&P 500 speaks
for itself
investors should be patient he says the
good news for Buffett is that one
opportunity has already fallen into his
lap this year
Berkshire pledged ten billion dollars to
buy preference shares in Occidental
Petroleum the Texas oil group needed
financing to back its fifty five billion
dollar takeover of rival and add Arco
petroleum that would help it win a
bidding war for Anadarko against larger
rival Chevron it was the first big birch
I deal in a while but even ten billion
dollars it's not as big as Buffett would
like the last truly big Berkshire take
over came in 2016 when Buffett's group
spent 37 billion dollars to purchase
industrial goods company Precision
Castparts it hasn't all been smooth
sailing for Berkshire and big deals in
fact the 2013 takeover of US condiments
group Heinz and later combined it with
kraft foods to create a major u.s. Foods
Group in 2015 two years later Kraft
Heinz tried to take over anglo-dutch
Group
you knew Eva for a hundred and forty
three billion dollars but it had to back
out after its approach was publicly
rebuffed Warren Buffett after all
doesn't like to be associated with
hostile deals since the Unilever bid
Kraft Heinz has struggled recently it
had to make a fifteen billion dollar
right now and even buffett had to admit
that he overpaid when combining craft
with heights so where will Buffett look
brexit britain where many companies
could face an uncertain future maybe one
place where Berkshire sees value in an
interview with the FT Buffett said he's
ready to buy something in the UK
tomorrow
[Music]